israeli airstrikes kill more civilians
in gaza palestinian leaders say the
cycle of violence needs to end so what's
needed to deliver permanent peace and
how does this latest round of attacks
jeopardize mediation efforts made so far
this is inside story
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
daddy inabugeda israel has carried out a
third day of airstrikes on gaza the
military says it's targeting the
positions of armed groups including
palestinian islamic jihad but it's
civilians who are bearing the brunt of
the worst violence since last year's
11-day war
dozens of people including children have
been killed since friday that's when
israel launched the attacks to prevent
the islamic jihad from retaliating after
the arrest of one of its commanders in
the occupied west bank the armed group
has fired more than 500 rockets into
israel palestinian prime minister
mohammad stayed says the cycle of
violence must stop
this happens once a year every few
months the aggression on gaza this
aggression should stop once and for all
we cannot just postpone to stop one
aggression so that israel can carry out
another aggression later and this should
be referred to the international
criminal court and the file is on the
table in front of the international
criminal court
let's take a look at some of the efforts
to end the violence an egyptian
intelligence delegation visited israel
on saturday before traveling to gaza on
sunday qatar a mediator in last year's
conflict has spent billions of dollars
helping to rebuild gaza it has
reaffirmed support for palestinians
while calling for international pressure
on israel to stop attacking civilians
the u.s state department says it stands
by israel's right to defend itself other
countries including morocco and the
united arab emirates have previously
offered to help mediate between the
israelis and the palestinians
let's now bring in our guests joining us
from dublin is yasir al-assad who's an
academic and specialist on the
israeli-palestinian conflict in
cambridge boston is ramiri a professor
at the american university of beirut and
a senior fellow at the harvard kennedy
school and joining us from washington
d.c is dan arbel scholar in residence at
the center for israeli studies at the
american university dan's also a former
israeli diplomat and negotiator in the
israel syria peace talks warm welcome to
you all thanks so much uh for joining us
on inside story yesterday
over in
dublin you say that if we see some sort
of ceasefire or mediation agreement it
will be similar to previous agreements
and you say that the short-term views
are the real problem can you explain
that thought process
yes of course
i think
as i said before
what we have seen in recent years
is short-term agreements that do not
address the core issues in terms of
palestinian rights in terms of
palestinian national rights in terms of
the wider israeli palestinian conflict
what we're seeing recently in terms of
gaza is a special focus on the
humanitarian aid a special focus on
short-term
security
and a focus on
reconstruction
which hasn't been really happening in
recent years
so as a result the core issues including
palestinian rights including justice
including self-determination freedom end
of occupation in the weber tide all of
those issues
haven't been addressed in those
mediation short-term agreements and
therefore i think the issues are going
to continue the conflict is going to
continue and all what we have seen as
well isn't only a
only a short-term process
in terms of managing this issue but we
also have seen
um
we have seen that um the process itself
of mediation has focused on conflict
management and not conflict resolution
and therefore from my perspective
those short term agreements and conflict
management processes will not produce
effective results in the long term
ramiri can you weigh in on this you say
that any mediation
tries to return calm
to the gaza strip but calm according to
you is an unacceptable situation tell us
why
of course calm is uh siege uh
restrictions uh israelis shooting
killing palestinians arresting people at
will
stopping the fishermen from working in
the sem i mean it's a total uh siege
situation which is a function of the
long-term
relationship between israel and zionism
on one hand and the palestinian people
on the other so calm is
not something that the palestinians see
as the long-term
uh of course in the short term it is
very good to stop the killing and the
fighting and the shooting on both sides
or whoever is involved
but
this happens regularly because the
underlying issues are not addressed uh
the egyptian government uh
it's fascinating that it's the security
intelligence agencies in egypt that are
in charge of this so this is a security
issue uh for egypt uh in fact everything
is a secured issue for egypt
like most arab countries and the
the egyptians are uh doing a good job in
trying to stop the actual destruction
and killing uh but not doing anything
more than that uh in terms of a
longer-term
horizon of some
expectation that the palestinians can
live a decent
life and one day uh have the same rights
to statehood and sovereignty and peace
and security as the israelis but the
egyptians do this because
um it it makes them look good with so
many audiences that are important to
them the uh their own population
the american government that funds them
the israeli government that deals with
them
the palestinian population so if egypt
can project itself as somebody who's
trying to reduce the suffering of people
in gaza
it resonates with a bunch of different
audiences that are important before so
this is typical of the situation where
arab governments use the palestine issue
for their own purposes while at the same
time egypt of course controls the
southern
gates of gaza and is
complicit with israel in the siege of
gaza right in egypt of course being one
of the mediators uh currently uh trying
to to to mediate some sort of uh truth
um uh dan or bell um to what extent do
you think israel is looking for a way
out
day three of attacks on gaza there have
been more than 500 rockets fired at
israel
sirens heard in tel aviv
i believe that israel would be
looking favorably at uh going for a
truce a ceasefire i believe that israel
has achieved
most of its goals in the operation it
launched on friday and i think that
what israel needs now is security
guarantees that islamic jihad will not
be
you know once a truce is agreed that
would be violated by the islamic jihad
and rockets would be fired again
from the gaza strip into israel
i think that uh there's a good chance
that that that um the ceasefire is
around the corner
and uh unfortunately this is something
that we've been seeing uh year after
year or year in year out
uh and there is um
no military solution to this issue i
think it's only a diplomatic solution to
this issue that could
pave the way for a long-term
uh
uh arrangement where where where there's
calm there's no
violence and that both sides uh tend to
their own issues rather than focus on uh
confronting one another
right so um
dan um
the israeli army had previously said
that actually there are currently no
negotiations with islamic jihad over a
ceasefire i mean is that just for the
public's consumption then
i think that you know over the years
there's never been direct negotiations
between israel hamas and previous
confrontations or with israel and
islamic jihad it's always done through
third parties and as my previous speak
the previous speaker noted the egyptian
role the qatari role there are other uh
the u.n other uh actors that are uh
stepping in
and trying to broker a ceasefire between
israel and islamic jihad i do not
believe that there is a direct
context or talks between israel and
islamic jihad yes sir you were
mentioning a moment ago that
the cycle of violence will continue if
uh
if
the the the issues at stake are are not
really addressed i mean
it's such a big question to you but
what needs to be done for for the issues
to be addressed so that the cycle of
violence does not uh happen over and
over
i don't think i was talking about the
cycle of violence i was talking about
the root issues and the root issues need
to be addressed and it's important that
they are addressed we're talking about
continuing israeli occupation we're
going to we're talking about
gaza being under siege for a long time
and that's important to remember we're
talking about 80 of the population in
gaza who are living on a humanitarian
aid we're talking about people in
jerusalem being evicted out of their
homes being forced out of their homes
we're talking about
palestinians as well in israel facing
discrimination and racism so for me this
is a question of the israeli regime of
and occupation that needs to be
addressed in order to have just and in
order to have just peace and in order to
have security for all
uh
for all peoples who are living in that
region um
your previous speaker was talking about
security guarantees that israel is
looking for in terms of gaza what about
security guarantees for palestinians who
have been under israeli occupation for
more than 60 years what about security
guarantees for gaza for people in gaza
who have been receiving israeli rockets
and civilians who are losing their their
their security and their lives under
israeli attacks what about security for
palestinians in the west bank and and
jerusalem so the the perspective on
palestinian security is not recognized
while the perspective on the israeli
security is recognized and therefore
that speaks um to an important issue
which is the power relationship between
palestinians and israelis and israel
continues to be a powerful um a powerful
country continues to be continues to
have a powerful military continues to
enjoy support from the united states and
europe and the palestinians i'm not
talking to them i'm not talking about
them as victims but nonetheless the
reality is they are living under israeli
an israeli regime of apartheid
occupation and racism and this needs to
be addressed dan is it ultimately about
the occupation as yasid is saying and
also i mean multiple human rights
organizations including a human rights
watch in 2021 describing israel's
systematic oppression and institutional
discrimination against palestinians
amnesty international as well in 2022
calling israel as apartheid against
palestinians a cruel system of
domination ultimately is it about the
occupation
though first of all i'd like to say that
uh gaza is not under israeli occupation
israel left the gaza strip in 2005
vowing not to come back and so since
2005
for the last 17 years israel has not
been inside gaza not inside gaza but
let's not kid ourselves it certainly
controls the land sea and air does it
not
correct so so what what what i'm getting
at is and as uh
i believe that the two-state solution is
the way forward is the way to resolve
the israeli-palestinian conflict having
a state of israel living side by side
with a
palestinian future palestinian state in
peace and security and uh once you know
that's
that happens then all these issues would
be on the table including the end of
occupation including
uh other aspects of borders settlement
security and then it could be
those issues can be addressed but let's
not forget that uh who's the aggressor
here and
having the palestinian-islamic jihad
holding the entire population of
southern israel is hostage threatening
to fire rockets and uh occasionally
doing that and so no no normal country
could allow itself to actually
uh allow this to happen and so israel
had to respond israel had to launch this
preemptive strike in order to deal with
this issue and let's talk about islamic
jihad there are no mother theresa's they
are a terrorist organization backed by
iran and vowing to destroy the state of
israel so israel has the right to defend
itself has the right also to worry about
its security and i agree that
palestinian security is important and
should be addressed as well rami would
you like to weigh in i saw you uh you
wanted to yeah please go ahead i have
several
to comment on some of dan's points i
mean he presented a very sophisticated
and uh
impressive presentation of israeli
propaganda and speaking points which
have been swallowed hookline and
sinclair by the american government the
british government and others around the
region um the the the idea
that uh all they want is peace and no
rockets out of gaza
uh it sounds good but the reality is
that groups like islamic jihad like
hamas like hezbollah like the armed wing
of fedex like the pflp and the dflp and
previous militant left-wing groups in
the 60s 70s
and 80s every one of these
resistance armed movements in palestine
or outside came about as a response to
continued israeli attacks occupation
subjugation apartheid racism
imprisonment expulsion killing arrest i
mean it's incredible that the israelis
and zionism for 100 years have not been
able to deal with the reality of
palestinian nationalism and sovereign
rights in palestine and even though he
says and i'm happy to hear him say that
he would like a two-state solution which
is what i've worked for all my life i
was born in 48
and this is great to hear but it is not
what the israeli government does it is
not what the american
government
does and the reality of these groups one
after the other emerging the muslim
brothers the hamas and all these moves
that keep emerging out of palestine in
fact many of them came out of gaza which
is fascinating gaza was has been the
incubator of palestinian nationalism
resistance and militant resistance for
about the last 50 or 60
years and it's always a result as a
response to what the israelis do so this
cycle has to be seen
as a cycle in which the israelis and
zionism are doing terrible things and
the palestinians are responding and they
do uh terrible things sometimes when
they
fire a missile or they used to do bomb
bombs and buses in tel aviv both sides
have used
different uh tactics that we can
criticize but the main thrust of why
this continues is because of the way
that zionism and the israeli government
continue to apply their policies while
camouflaging them in this very
sophisticated public relations uh
approach that doesn't work anymore so
the whole world
basically accept the american presidency
a few people in congress people in
england running for prime minister this
individual who repeat these lines
that israel has a
right to defend itself but the majority
of public opinion around the world is
saying we want equal rights for israelis
and palestinians and that means reality
not rhetoric and i hope we can move from
rhetoric
to reality and the palestinians have put
their cards on the table many times for
a two-state solution but the israelis
and the americans and others do not
respond okay uh just back to the issue
of the egyptian mediation yasser rami
was mentioning this just a few moments
ago about the role that egypt has been
playing historically but for palestinian
factions how important is egypt as a
partner obviously its geographical
proximity must play a part here
egypt is an important player from a
geographical point if you know from its
geopolitical point of view
also from an economic point of view
egypt continues to enjoy
very strong relations with the
palestinian factions
and continues to enjoy strong relations
with the palestinian authority with
hamas and also with israel and indeed
with the united states so israel sorry
egypt is a regional player and it's a
significant player now the egyptian
mediation is important for two factors
or for two reasons one and it has a
strong relationship um with israel so
so egypt can communicate with israel
messages
and can also
manage talks in terms of palestinians in
gaza they can and they have a strong
relationship with hamas
and hamas continues to be a significant
player in gaza and
and i think both palestinians and
israelis trust palestinians sorry trust
egyptian mediation
and egypt continues to enjoy influence
continues to enjoy good relations and
also continues to enjoy international
support in terms of its
mediation efforts
also let's not forget that egypt has um
direct borders with gaza and and egypt
continues to control the rafah crossing
which is a major land border between
gaza and the outside world
and um and egypt also continues to
support humanitarian aid into gaza
but let me
just go back to the main point that i
made earlier which is all of these
short-term agreements will not be
successful as long as we do not address
first of all palestinian reconciliation
it needs to be addressed and supported
secondly the israeli regime of upper
tide and occupation that the
palestinians have been living under
since 1948 if this system isn't
addressed this aggressive system and
policy isn't addressed we are likely
going to see more aggression more
violence and and and also more
instability over the coming years right
and as long as
as long as the united states continues
to support israel and not to support a
political settlement we're going to see
more more instability as well over the
coming years dan you're a former
diplomat and the negotiator as well from
your point of view what does this
mediation actually achieve i mean cairo
has attempted several times egypt as
well as others have attempted several
times to uh to push for some sort of
reconciliation process between israel
and at the time uh it was hamas
so so i think that israel and egypt have
a uh close coordination available
uh
over the years and so i believe that
israel sees uh the egyptian uh option
the egyptian channel
as as the best way
to try and resolve the the outstanding
issues and to reach a ceasefire egypt
has proven
over the last several years over
previous conflicts that it's able to
deliver uh when it comes to bringing the
palestinian
side to the table or to agree to the
conditions of the truth perhaps
short-term successes dan but we're
talking here about sort of long-term
solutions
correct so so
you know the issue is that none of the
parties are looking long-term and that's
a problem uh there's a problem that
israel's not looking long-term egypt is
not looking long-term and the
palestinians for sure are not looking
for long-term and if you don't look for
long-term it's it's a problem because
each every few months or every few years
you face the same
uh problem again and again and i think
it's an issue of leadership
i think it's an issue of political
circumstances that uh that can make this
uh uh happen
but uh these have not uh crystallized
yet and it will take time and
unfortunately innocent people are hurt
or losing lives and are uh just under
under threat of violence and uh until
there is a long-term approach by all
parties nothing is going to move forward
unfortunately
when you look at what's happening right
now in gaza from your assessment what
kind of
intensity and length of conflict could
we potentially be seeing
my guess is that the immediate conflict
will wind down in the next few days
uh hamas is unlikely to join in the uh
fight or some of the other smaller armed
factions uh but we'll see i mean it
depends what the israelis do if the
israelis go around killing more people
and destroying more infrastructure and
if they hit some of the other groups
then you might get an expansion of the
actual fighting but i don't expect that
because the fighting has expanded many
times in the last 20 years
and it just doesn't uh solve anything
there is no military solution to this
nor is there a solution through the
israeli policies of apartheid and siege
and restriction and dehumanization
the only solution is a negotiated one
that gives both people uh equal rights
and statehood but the most important
thing the israelis i think need to
recognize which they probably know deep
down but are not able or willing to to
admit is that every time they have
carried out their policy of what they
call mowing the lawn or mowing the grass
every few years they attack gaza they
destroy some things but every time in
the wake of that kind of israeli attack
the militant forces in gaza get more
public support as they're doing now
because islamic jihad despite the
criticism people make of it
is the only group that is now seen to be
resisting israel even though they're not
going to liberate palestine that putting
up a show of resistance generates great
support for them and the other thing
that happens is they become more
technologically sophisticated if you
look at hamas and islamic jihad and
hezbollah and even the houthis and yemen
they get support from the iranians and
the syrians and other people and they
help each other
they have become increasingly more
sophisticated to the point in lebanon
where
israel have a ceasefire they're afraid
to fight each other because they know
they'll be massive destruction so israel
has to look at the long-term
consequences of what it does and then
look at a peace strategy one day all
right we'll have to leave it there thank
you so much for joining us
we thank you so much for your time
thanks for watching you can see the
program again anytime by visiting our
website aljazeera.com for further
discussion you can go to our facebook
page that's facebook.com forward slash
aj inside story join the conversation on
twitter our handle is aj inside story
from myself and the whole team here in
delhi thanks for watching bye for now
[Music]
you